well welcome everyone I'm dr. Matthew
Mian I am the director of academic
programs here at the LMP Kirby jr.
center for constitutional studies and
citizenship where we think a lot about
the principles of our Constitution but
also about the nation and its people and
what it means to be a citizen and what
all that entails if done well and to
that end I have with me today author
Timothy P Carney who's written alienated
America and Tim is the commentary editor
at the Washington Examiner and a
visiting fellow of the American
Enterprise Institute he's written a
number of books including the big ripoff
and Obama nominee and he's here to talk
about his book today but I think a
proper introduction might include things
like Tim and I built the deck together
once Tim and I have shared a drink now
and again and our kids have been on
t-ball and baseball teams together and
so if we're looking in nated America no
better place to start than a good
conversation between friends
so without further ado Tim why don't you
I'm gonna do to you what John Miller did
to me when he had me up here which is
why don't you give us a sort of
30-second elevator pitch but rather than
to a publisher is your publisher how
about to a Broadway musical you've got
right there who how do you write this as
a musical well you've got three three
main characters right you've got the
elites you've got the religious
conservatives and you have the alienated
and these represent most of America so
the community and
civil society has been eroding in
America this is something Robert Putnam
wrote about in in Bowling Alone and it's
been eroding for everybody but not
equally and the working class one of the
main ways that they're suffering is that
they don't have the institutions that
connect them to other people that
provide them with a sense of purpose a
safety net modeling and meanwhile though
there are two other characters in this
musical and one all around here
Washington DC where everybody has
college degrees lots of people have
advanced degrees and guess what
they are living the conservative life
even if they're not voting that way
getting finishing school getting a job
getting married having kids being
involved in their kids lives and their
community lives but then the third
character will call her holly van heme
straw is a Dutch Christian Reformed
person living in iceberg Wisconsin where
I think this musical probably takes
place after after a bus goes off the
road in the snow or something and a news
Berg Wisconsin they have all the same
good outcomes as Chevy Chase Maryland up
the road here but without the money what
they have bringing them together are the
churches that create the fundamental
core of the strong civil society for the
middle class and so then you realize
that with the alienated characters what
happened was secularization and
deinstitutionalization led to this
alienation and thus the deaths of
despair the dropping out of college the
I mean out of high school the out of
wedlock births
and the dropping out of the labor force
mmm sort of a planes trains and
automobiles yeah reboots kind of thing
yeah so what is alienation then what
what does that mean so one definition of
alienation I use in there is by Robert
Nesbit who was a he was a fellow at AEI
where I'm I do a fellowship and he said
it's something very interesting I had to
read it twice alienation is a state of
mind of not being connected to society
but also not seeing the point of being
kin
to society and to see both of those
that's really important but practically
and we can we should go deeper on that
later but practically alienation can a
family can be alien you could be married
with your kids and if you're not trying
to raise if you're not able to raise
your family together with neighbors with
some other institutions it's a lot
harder and you're it's a lot less likely
to fail I use the image of the cyclops
from The Odyssey in there where the
cyclops the if you guys have read The
Odyssey he's his beast he has only one
eye
it lives on this island he's terrifying
when you read it really closely Cyclops
is kind of a family man right like he's
in the cave with his wife or wives I
don't remember and all his kids but he
doesn't interact with his neighbors so I
would say the main way I see alienation
in America today is not belonging to the
institutions of civil society that is
not just you don't have many friends
it's you don't belong to something it's
a lack of belonging and what goes along
with it as Nisbet points out is not
seeing the point of blowing right and
that inability to see what are some of
the causes of that blindness essentially
right if they if the alienated can't see
why they should join mm-hmm what are
some of the causes of that I know I mean
I might ask that the other way or put it
the other way that I think most people
don't see the a lot of people don't see
the value of these connections and
either because the JD Vance and
hillbilly ology used the term because
his story was he lived in one of these
alienated suburbs if you guys remember
hillbilly ology his family moved out of
the holler in Kentucky he lands in
Middletown Ohio and there's just no
connection as families falling apart
his mom can't get her act together to
build a new family and he says when he
finally got to law school just cuz he
was really bright he realized that
connection and knowing people was
immensely valuable he always thought it
was just gonna be achievement
achievement achievement and just he's
gonna and he said the people around me
who had these connections
didn't realize what it was because it
was the air that they breathe it's like
why a fish doesn't notice the water and
so a lot of us don't see the value of
connection even if we're connected I
mean right now I mean I often say where
our circles are often the overlap of
these two the religious conservative and
the elite and it can be easy to take it
for granted the the institutions that
give you the sense of purpose on the
safety net are also the ones who are
always like asking you to do more and it
can almost seem annoying and so you
don't necessarily see it when you in it
when you're in it and you don't
necessarily see it when you're out of it
so that I'd take a step back from your
question and say why is it so hard for
us to understand and even notice civil
society and even the political debate is
often individualism versus more
government and a lot of conservatives
and libertarians argue that
individualism is the answer to more
government that's what I neurons whole
shtick was and so again that's missing
the middle bonds is it is it wrong to
say then am i hearing you saying that we
shouldn't pin this on the alienated and
the downtrodden this blindness but it's
actually a national blindness yeah and
that the elites one of the three
characters here yeah Hamilton the Ducks
the elites are are actually failing
their air job of communicating this yes
and even of of noticing it and certainly
articulating its value one of the things
I argue I think a lot so I point out
that if you have a college degree in a
higher education you are more likely to
to favor more redistribution of wealth
and so that's sort of a an empirical
reinforcement of an idea that you're
more likely to be a liberal if you're an
elite but they think that too many
people think that what they have going
for them that their most valuable asset
is their money their income or in some
ways of the the status conferred upon
them by their to group by their degrees
and I are you know it's that they're
plugged in and
connected the most valuable asset of the
people in Chevy Chase Maryland and I
pick on Chevy Chase in the beginning of
the book because it's a wealthiest
municipality in this region which is a
wealthiest region in this country which
is wealthiest country in the history of
the world the most valuable asset they
have is that it's not there 1.5 million
dollar house they're paying 1.5 million
dollars for a house they can live in a
place where their kids are riding
tricycles up and down the street where
the little leagues and if if they want
the Catholic parish all of these things
are intent are these tight overlapping
tightly knit institutions of civil
society that gives you better access to
the good life and so the elite failure
sometimes conservatives like to say they
don't preach what they practice right
and I don't put that much stake and most
people preaching that much I think the
main thing is they're not willing to
realize it especially the ones that are
able to implement public policy that the
community institutions a connection they
have that that is the most valuable
thing that they have that's the greatest
asset now in the book you make a you you
make a kind of several categories and
you talk about one of them being the
combination of big government and big
business and I think if I got you
correctly you say big business that
promises lower prices right because of
economies of scale yep and big
government the promises efficiency yep
now that all reduces prices at the cost
of community with regard to
centralization why can't we then say
that really America has essentially
decided they're not willing to just
they're not willing to pay the costs for
civil society they just they don't want
to pay it right it's sort of a it's a
free-market argument then they've just
decided no yeah we're not we don't to
pay those costs we like efficiency which
reduces costs in government and we like
lower prices at Walmart so to some
extent you can I mean if we brought my
earlier two books up on Sage I could I
was going
as how the progression of your two books
so my first two books were the subtitle
of the big ripoff is how big business
and big government to feel your money
the first draft of it was why big
business lobbies foreign profits from
bigger government so to some extent
economic centralization is not the fruit
of free market capitalism but of
government intervention that's an
important point but I think maybe a more
interesting point is that community we
often nobody chooses very few people
choose community because they say I want
to have more connection and private
little safety net and something to give
me a sense of purpose you belong to
something because there's some more
visible bet benefit and sometimes it's
perfectly spiritual sometimes I'm going
to Mass because I'm obligated to
sometimes it's I'm joining this church
because it's the best way for me to
volunteer and feed my neighbors and that
sort of thing sometimes it's I'm going
to my local diner because they have
coffee and eggs but all of these choices
to step into an institution have all
these unanticipated less visible but
very crucial benefits and I think that
to go back to your earlier question a
lot of civil society is that that we
don't it's very hard for any of us to
see the value and we kind of can
accidentally end up tapping into it so
with regard to economics here I kind of
start chapter two in 1955 in Pittsburgh
and a blue-collar guy with a high school
degree working in a steel factory and
the fact is that life is good for him
he's able to if he can put in the 30
years show up on time do all that work
his wife can say at home if she wants to
and with some overtime in 15 years or
buying a little cabin on the lake and a
fishing boat and then they can retire
with dignity and that's not possible
anymore because of economic efficiency
so America's wealthier because we have
more trade with China with Europe and
all that stuff so we didn't choose to be
inefficient to provide this it was sort
of almost an accident
Europe was devastated by the war there
wasn't as much navigable sea ways and
for that white working-class guy he was
protected from competition from black
people people in foreign countries
people who wanted to be hear from women
so all of these things that are not
things that anybody would or should
deliberately design had created this
sort of nice situation for the white
working-class guy outside of Pittsburgh
and so just because there's an
efficiency to be gained and there's
progress to be made by changing that
situation doesn't mean there's not a
real loss and so I cite the economic
studies by David autor who was a great
MIT economist who pointed out the places
that were competing with China the most
they didn't just have a downturn in
wages they had an uptick in unemployment
an uptick in men then dropping out of
the labor force a downturn in marriage
and up taken out of wedlock births and
ultimately of spike in death of despair
suicide drug overdoses alcohol deaths so
good for the whole country all of the
progress racial gender free-trade
efficiency but bad for these places yeah
and that's the question that you raised
I think that the question how do you
actually deal with the problem of place
and I'm thinking of it in regard to that
you talk about halide bubbles and elite
enclaves and this area and mega seeds
have you seen any previews for or heard
about Peter Jackson's movie mortal
engines no where essentially there's
some post nuclear apocalypse everyone
says forget it the cities have to be
mobile so we're gonna put them on
half-tracks and move London around right
but then they start devouring other
cities and sort of just eating them to
sustain themselves what happened to
these smaller communities and why didn't
why didn't they have the sort of robust
civil society safety net yeah that
you've been you talk about in in the
book what so I mean a good
good comparison I go to Uniontown
Pennsylvania in Fayette County south of
Pittsburgh and I also discuss Pittsburgh
where I went in my travels both of these
places were devastated by the closure of
a lot of steel mills and by the the coal
industry dying but Pittsburgh's doing
really well right now and the the
Uniontown is not I mean the the stories
I tell from Smitty's bar are depressing
people talking about seeing drug needles
at the kids school bus stop so the
parents the mom while dropping off her
kids presumably is is there with her
needles why is Fayette County doing so
poorly while Pittsburgh is doing so well
and the simplistic answer which is
partly true is well in Pittsburgh a lot
of these industrialists invent invested
in things that could be good employers
like the health care system in
universities but if we only see them as
employers we're missing half the story
they also invested in art museums in
parks and then there was a bunch of
little neighborhoods you've got the
Italian parish over here you've got
Squirrel Hill with the the Tree of Life
synagogue as its center over here dense
overlapping networks of civil society
institutions the big ones that were
sitting wide the little neighborhood
ones and then the public schools stay
strong because people are staying in
their neighborhood people are committed
even though times are have turned down a
little bit and what's preserved even if
the money is a little bit down is the
human capital because the community
institutions what they do is they're
preserving strong education making it
easier for people to get married and
raise families and just people are in
better shape go out to Uniontown maybe
in some of the smaller places in Fayette
County Fayette City for instance there's
one Protestant church and one Catholic
very Catholic Church closes down the
bishop says oh you your church isn't
closed you're just being consolidated
with st. Raphael's 20 miles away st.
Raphael's was probably your like
archrival when you were in CYO
basketball you're not going to go there
I mean I talked to people in the
Pittsburgh air
said they stopped going to church when
their parish closed down and so a lot is
lost there even if you're looking at it
from a secular perspective the diner
where the factory workers used to go
shuts down and people become alienated
and then they lose their human capital
so if you're an employer 20 years later
you show up you're not gonna set up in
Fayette County you might set up in
Pittsburgh
well the wages are a little low because
there's high unemployment but the human
capital is high and not so high in the
end the places where the civil society
was thinner where I imagine people sort
of falling and the safety net a
Pittsburgh can catch them long enough
for them to pack bounce back this thin
piece of paper in Uniontown they're
falling and they bring with them the
parish the diner and the Little League
do you see that as you start the
description you start in Pittsburgh and
then you go up into the Alleghenies
right to these to these steel towns do
you see it as this jobs of cities to
sort of export through suburb to X herb
to Elk County those sorts of habits in
some sense I don't know those places
were lying on the big cities it used to
be simply that so charles murray and
coming apart argues that there was just
a more even distribution of skills in a
time when we were less mobile so there's
a clear downside to that like you have
to take a job in your hometown and so
the kid who's a she's the smartest kid
in the whole school clearly could go to
Princeton and become a doctor may end up
becoming the principal of the local high
school that's really good for the kids
of Newton Iowa it's a loss for you know
the aggregate GDP of the United States I
just gave a talk at a Classical School
in st. Louis and that Latin teacher is a
Harvard grad and if this tiny little
Cinda just started in a shopping mall
yeah that's gonna go well for you guys
that's helpful but that that that's a
lot less
common so that could just be it that it
used to be if you were looking to set up
a factory there were ten thousand towns
in the US where you could be like I
could get some good workers in any of
these sounds now you're looking to go
anywhere and think about when Amazon was
doing their job search what were they
looking at places with high
concentrations of skilled workers
perfectly and a bunch of handouts but
the high confidence we ignore that part
um the high concentration of skilled
workers is a is a really good thing but
there is something about the the skilled
workers the PTA moms the t-ball coaches
being more equally distributed in the
past that had a good result now the
problem is we're in Washington and you
think you're you talk about a problem
you always want a solution you can't
force people to say in their hometown so
we can't forcibly I mean I know people
who would think about this redistribute
high IQ hard-working extroverts around
the country so we're describing a
problem that is the fruit of a sense of
progress in an efficiency but how do you
so we have some friends in this town
probably more than another towns but who
are somewhat more socialist in their
leanings mmm-hmm and they would say Tim
look the steel mill got things going in
you know the river valleys and and and
in the Alleghenies and they're the the
sole sort of economic problem you just
flood of jobs and cash right and habits
of just doing it and then they shut down
and the thing dies it's absolutely about
the economy stupid that's the big thing
if you can get jobs to these people if
you can get money so they can have a
household in a home right that's it
that's the whole ball of wax because it
appeared because of those mills those
places and then they died because of
those mills that explanation is almost
always skipping a few steps is what I
would argue so the three answers I have
one is the Pittsburgh and Fayette County
one Pittsburgh and Fayette County both
suffered from the loss of jobs but
Pittsburgh civil society held it up
second explanation is a Williston North
Dakota the the church on the front of
the book there is right outside of
Williston North Dakota it's a it's
Williston is this fracking town so they
found the the Permian Shale under
there and they out of nowhere just a ton
of jobs appeared so people would travel
all over and and you could lay in there
with a high school degree once you pass
your drug tests you get an 18 hour $18
an hour job and so this one social
economists
Melissa Kearney no relations you spell
the difference she's at Brookings
Institution she said oh the middle class
the working class where the wages have
dropped they are the ones that have
retreated from marriage again the elites
are practicing that with the
Conservatives are preaching the working
class is getting married at a far far
lower rate so what happens when the
working class get good high paying jobs
and she didn't just look at Wilson she
looked at places that weren't as remote
in mostly the places that weren't as
remote
Pennsylvania Texas what happens in a
place lots of working-class people were
the guys all of a sudden get good-paying
jobs because male wages that predict
marriage not female wages the women in
those towns were not getting married at
any higher rate after the good-paying
jobs came in they were having babies at
a slightly higher rate but not getting
married at any higher rate and so what I
argue is this is because what make what
made the working class retreat from
marriage was not simply a drop in wages
it was the concomitant retreat of civil
society and erosion of those
institutions the churches not just a
church is being out there preaching you
ought to get married but providing again
our kids play on the same baseball teams
the the neighboring parish is where
they're playing now there's just these
six awesome baseball coaches I was
watching them the other day they're
running the practice really well I
coached Tomas in in t-ball or coach
pitch baseball or whatever it's easier
to raise kids when there's lots of
people like that around you and then
institutions like a parish or a little
league or a bowling league or whatever
through which these people these people
can provide these services to your kids
to your wife to your family and so
those institutions aren't there in the
blue-collar places that have been
suffering for a generation they can
slowly come back but if the money lands
there but the money's probably not going
to land there unless either a there
sitting on top of a bunch of oil or B
there were strong communities here to
preserve the human capital and it's a
desirable sort of base of employment
I noticed you you you spend some time
talking about Utah and Mormon
communities and in one sense it's it's
when you think of Salt Lake City and the
mountains of Salt Flats of Utah
you don't think of wow the promised land
you know it's all about the you know the
the ripe and fertile valleys of Utah and
you know there are plenty but that's a
religious community that started from
nothing but religious fervor to go live
as they wish yeah and so I went out
there and that's where I had the head of
the conservative think tanks a Hillary
was right it takes a village so talking
about raising children yeah you need
strong support and community and family
the on the state flag of Utah is a
beehive now when Hillary says it takes a
village or if Bernie Sanders started
talking about a beehive you would start
worrying about collectivism socialism
that sort of thing beehive I mean they
like the the worker bees are just slaves
to the Queen and the drones are actually
like sex slaves to the queen and the
queen is in charge of everything and but
in your defense of their defense
Vergil talks about the beehive is an
image for the human community yes and so
that's that's the thing is the but when
you look at it and like imagine in its
early days especially religious settlers
yes they're all going to work for the
common good and if you've ever been on
something sometimes you see analogy of
the men's baseball team I used to play
on and nobody was setting like
incentives or punishments for playing
hard or showing up on time right you
were just part of something you cared
about the outcome and so you did it and
that's what you know a parish is like a
lot of strong
institutions are like that and so that
when I was out there and Utah that's
what I found is this like real
conservatism that even extends over to
like really constantly preaching
self-reliance as a term that's very
commonly used in the LDS Church
self-reliance is a virtue at the same
time that your duty to care for your
neighbor is huge so one of the stories I
ran into there and I thought about this
compared to the government welfare state
was a guy who now runs the it's kind of
a food kitchen it's a grocery store
called the bishop storehouse where you
go and you can pick up your food for
free if if you need it and you're your
local kind of a pastor sort of advisor
in your local parish or your ward fills
out a form of what you need so this guy
had lost a job and Don who was the whose
job it was in his parish shows up at his
house you've lost your job what do you
have literally stored up in your pantry
and so they go through that what do you
have in your savings account
what's your rent your insurance etc and
they go through it he's like okay so for
the first two weeks you've got savings
and you've got food in your pantry two
weeks after that you're going to need a
little bit of help but also you have
this fishing boat and the guy was like
Don yet it's not like an a an
extravagance I go fishing with my kids
and he goes yes but remember if you go
and start drawing food out of the
bishops storehouse how is that paid for
that's paid for by voluntary donations
of the other people in Salt Lake City
and where does that money come from
their practices we're going to give up a
meal what is it once a week and the
price of that meal is we're going to
donate to fund the bishop storehouse so
are you asking your neighbors to give up
a meal for them and their kids so that
you can keep your fishing boat because
if you sell that fishing boat then it's
six weeks out that you can keep paying
for it and by then you'll probably have
a job and so when you tell this story
it's very interesting some people all
that's absurdly intrusive as opposed to
the government asking new
like for you to pee in a cup and take
this drug tests and all the other things
where you're either gonna slip through
the cracks so there's all these cases of
fraud this to me was charity done with
love and accountability on a local level
thinking motivated by a higher cause and
I thought so much public policy is an
attempt to replicate that without the
love and without the accountability yeah
without the love you talk a lot about
the difference between transactional
versus relational could you expand on
that well what is the what's wrong with
transactions I mean isn't a free market
doc right I mean I loved I loved
transactions we need transactions we
have transactions every day I only got a
ride here because of transaction with
you know a cabbie and but relational is
where you're I mean this is is where
you're putting in what you can and
taking out what you need which of course
is what marks off to that right from
each according to his means to each
according to his needs but communism
with love I guess is what I mean by
relational that the worst relationship
advice I ever got was somebody saying
you ought to look at your marriage as
sort of having a ledger and so you do a
favor for your wife and then she'll do
one for you and yeah it was really bad
advice I mean following effort but what
about an alienated America what are you
doing a marriage you pour in what you
have and you hope to take out so
neighbors true neighborliness is doing
what your neighbors need but also not
totally selflessly that's part of what I
mean by relationally with sort of a
knowledge that you're going to get what
you need so helping people move we've
talked about a friendship we have
repeatedly helped one another move it is
like a blood oath I will be there
I asked 18 people to help me move and
sixteen of them showed up one of them
was in Iraq and
other one have like had like kidney
stone yes I'm cancer and so that's that
wasn't me
counting up everybody I had out move but
I like helping people move and these
guys will do it even though it's an
expenditure of social capital so that's
the thing relational versus
transactional I think that's a big
problem we are increasing a
transactional culture and I mean really
somebody could write a book just
transactional culture that you expect to
get something for everything you put in
we need a transactional economy for a
huge part of the economy but some part
of our life has to be more relational
now with regard to sort of building up
this sort of social capital is one way
of talking about community is the sort
of Nisbet phrase and I actually just
this is sort of more of a public
announcement I think a lot about this in
sort of old-school Republican terms of
community being the the type of
relational transactions if you want to
put it you know yeah get it all in there
the type of relationships that deal with
the human body like you need money you
need food you need clothing you need
schools dealing with family and bodies
and society is sort of a little more
free ranging because it's more about
your mind that you can have a big alien
society and some day you've never met
but you write letters about Hegel or
something in Germany whose burg Germany
has a pizza Wisconsin and the community
is more tactile and and physical it what
do you what do you make of the the the
sort of understanding of the community
as or I shouldn't say what do you make
of it why do you put the church right
and church-going as this is sort of the
the queen in the middle of the
chessboard sore like here's the big
power move and you put it out there and
it's kind of startling in the book where
you sort of like okay boom what yeah the
middle chapter is called it's about I
notice it was right in the middle very
nice um I went to st. John's right
and so less it'll writers put their most
important teaching in the smack dab
middle of the books yeah so the mine my
secret teaching is it's about church and
so what well so first of all the key
point the key word I use in the two
words are use in the it's about Church
chapter our attendance is the first one
the sociological data religious people
have very religious people have far
better outcomes and whether it's their
children you know not going to jail
their children finishing school their
marriage is saying together then not
having drugs not falling out of the
labor force but the key thing if you
look at measures of self expressed like
seriousness of belief or frequency of
prayer those don't really have any
upward effect on the numbers attendance
is what produces a good outcome that
sort of the sociological explanation
belonging is the more sort of human
level thing if you go to a church
regularly you belong to something and
belonging means people need you people
know you people will take care of you
the the preface of the book is when our
daughter was in the hospital and one
part of it is all the food we got I mean
we it was like an overwhelming amount of
food people brought us because we
couldn't make dinner
when my son read this he goes dad he
should have included the fact that we
were envied by the other kids at school
cuz our lunches were better than theirs
one but I heard about it yes
I heard about this one family brought us
sandwiches from the corner bakery and
just like a giant tray of them and so we
had to like give him to lunch it was a
dinner it was everything um but then one
of my other favorite moments was my wife
was at the late morning Mass when she
finally looked at her phone and I said
I'm sprinting to the area the ER and she
just turned to her daughter and said you
stay here go sit with Dorie she'll give
you a ride home and otherwise somebody
else will and that moment and when I
wrote about that and people I got this
flood of response of people saying thank
you that's that's what I get from my my
church community it's it's as belonging
but the other reason it's at the center
of the book and on the cover of the book
is that we talk about institutions of
civil society and for the middle class
and the working class in America the
church has always been the core
institution of civil society and the
secularization of this country has been
manageable for the elites who first of
all actually go to church if you take
the top 20 percent go to church more
than the bottom 20 percent but have
other institutions to fall back on
whether it's their alumni networks
professional networks their communities
where the one of the parents is more
likely to have flexible work hours if
you have a blue-collar job there's a
good job that you don't have flexibility
or your boss tells you here's your
schedule for the next two weeks that
person can't coach t-ball can't be in
the PTA because they don't know when
they're gonna be on-call right but what
do you what do you say to this sort of
you you have a whole section on
secularization and this sort of
antipathy to church that you get in sort
of coastal elite circles but you know
it's kind of a broader culture elite
opinion what do you get how do you
respond to this notion of yes true we
all came over here as sort of religious
exiles to set up colonies Maryland and
Boston yeah Salt Lake and these these
religious minorities for freedom of
religion but you know that's the past we
have the future why can't we progress is
something else and why can't the source
of belonging that unifying force be a
really wonderful communi
Center that is not religious that is
secular based on science and reason
alone we can do this we can beat God how
do you how do you argue against that if
you know yeah the grounds are a sense of
belonging or non alienation there's a
first of all there's very little
evidence of that existing there's elite
circles and they're strong religious
communities and that's where you get
good outcomes there can be other things
that are very local so in New England in
New York you get strong public schools
that are actually controlled by the
local people that's the closest thing to
something of a replacement but it's it's
rare and it's kind of fairly intermixed
with the the religious and the elite
circles but I would say that the that
virtue is I think what's going to be
missing from a secular attempt to
replicate this that instead it gets
replaced with sort of best practices and
this is ironic for me to say in some
ways because there's tons of
sociological stuff in there but I I
begin and I end with real human stories
I begin with my daughter going to the
hospital and I end with sort of building
a city and speech a parish in speech and
you know bringing neighbors in the poor
and all that stuff together I begin and
end with human stories because I think
ultimately the this is a community story
but individual virtue I should say
virtue is going to be at the core of it
and the elites right now the the best
secular communities we're having
I don't think our inculcating virtue
they describe it as a best practice they
know that if you wait to have sex your
life is more likely to end better off
they know you should finish school and
then get a job and then get married
because that's what the social science
data show you but I don't think that
there's indications and I have some
numbers in near the end of chapter 11
there that that doesn't succeed in
passing on a dedication to community I
call infertile virtue and that to have a
a shared higher purpose that you're
engaged in is
necessary to communities and I think
that the only thing that makes that
shared higher purpose hold up is it
actually being a higher cause hmm yeah I
thought I think that you've got another
argument that I thought maybe you would
you would offer and I one of our four
because I think it's for secular people
who don't believe it's a it's a powerful
one is used
I thought you demonstrated quite well
the notion of you can't do it because
there's not enough money in the world to
actually fund that kind of thing that
the the sort of spiritual resource of a
church community that that is always
going to be there for people without
tons of means and lots of other and this
is an iceberg Wisconsin or Orange City
that they are replicable the raw
material of this is God people who want
to serve their community the raw
material of Chevy Chase's Odell's and
oodles of cash and a lot of liberal
public policy is look at the great
outcomes in these elite places let's
spend enough money to make everybody
elites that doesn't work I don't
necessarily want to make everybody
Mormons or burgers but something closer
to that is more replicable than making
everybody chevy chase and if building
community does have all these sorts of
it reinforces the sequence of success
and and and winds up starting to build
up all these other economic fruits and
more material fruits that people sort of
point to a see this is great there is it
seems to me there is a kind of a binary
choice there so you either are headed in
that direction of rebooting community
then through church in people right read
the book it's much more complicated than
that in one sense but it does boil down
and one sense or you really do say I
don't know another solution other than
appropriating all money's and
distributing it is sort of you know
think everyone gets one for you one for
you one for you but
but you seem to argue to that that even
won't work with regard to you you have a
whole section on Aristotle I'm a
political philosophy guy myself there
was I guess the political animal why
can't that work period why can't why
can't the the the even if you did
redistribute all the income yeah well so
I mean let's just assume it has been
done happiest ride in 1917 wasn't a
great look well first of all like people
need to be agents of people need to
exercise their political muscles you're
not supposed to just live your own life
but all sort of shape the world around
you and I know we have a couple least a
couple libertarians in this room and so
I don't I don't mean to say you should
be managing other people's lives but
shaping the world around you is what it
means that we're supposed to be
political animals and my my main way I
hid the world around me is not through
my columns or TV appearances or anything
like that I don't think I've changed a
dime of federal spending but it's to
exempt ban except for the export-import
bank very big come on tell Jim go but
mostly it's again there's there's a
baseball programs as small as it is in
our parish because of efforts that I and
this other guy have done and there's the
intersection near our house actually is
a little bit change the lights and the
line that's my wife and I lobbied our
local government on that local personal
level is how you get to exercise your
political muscles if you take that power
away from people put it in the central
government as Bernie Sanders would you
then liberate everybody from the duty to
serve their neighbors right because the
central state is providing and this is
the Tocqueville spends pages and pages
on this and then once that's happening
then we're not actually living out our
lives as political animals and this is
where Tocqueville said it would be wrong
to call this paternalistic because no
father worth the name would raise his
kids in such a way that they never had a
duty to care for other people it's worse
than paternalist
it's it's keeping people perpetually as
children so if you strip from people the
responsibility to serve their neighbors
through some massive redistribution then
you're stripping their ability to live
their lives and again I tell stories in
there from iceberg from Salt Lake City
from and also Chevy Chase or Fairfax
County or other elite places of people
finding their meaning in life through
relations and through serving other
people and you can't take that away from
people and still expect good outcomes
yeah the last question that I'm gonna
ask them will open it up to everyone
else's take us through a few of the more
practical solutions and I will I'll try
to throw a barb here sort of I found
myself reading the solutions and going
yes yes good yes but but then I pause I
said well wait a minute what about
structural questions yeah constitutional
questions I mean here we're at the Kirby
Center yeah and I this is not I'm not
springing this on you I told you I was
gonna do this but but what about the
repeal of the 17th amendment getting
place re-established right I know it's
got a bad names
yes rights people recoil from that but
you seem to talk a lot about how places
not necessarily large population centers
mm-hmm are need places having identity
and people being attached to and again
go to a neighbor go to Park Slope in
Brooklyn and the wealthy elite hipsters
are proud to be from Park Slope so they
will say they will use like blood and
soil as a curse word in their column in
The New York Times and then go home and
be super proud of their particular Block
in Park Slope tribalism is a natural
part of human life and it's going to be
rooted in place even in this
technological age which oh I have to
pick up on the 17th amendment exactly
you can't be what but what what sort of
things are there yeah well I'll just
give the one I know you start with go to
church rectory
but but what structure so if you want it
so there's little fiddly this tax code
should stop favoring really big
expensive houses because that's what the
sand the mortgage interest deduction
does it doesn't make more people
homeowners it makes people buy bigger
houses and that that's so that's like a
example of sort of a one-off but you're
pointing towards politics that
reestablishes the importance of place
and so when we were talking about this
earlier it was sort of about like your
representation think about I mean my
congressional district I think is
different from your congressional
district and you live five minute drive
from me and both of them stretch from
the DC border up to Pennsylvania border
so in his congressional district it has
the Bethesda Country Club and it has
Allegheny County which is like the West
Virginia part of Maryland there is no
community of interest that used to be a
term that courts would use for a valid
way to draw congressional lines was
community of interest as far as I know
that's disappeared compactness is a good
virtue right people should live
physically close to each other but
community of interest is sort of a
sister thing that what if you had a
congressional district that was the
people who were the farmers and then you
or state legislative district here's the
farmers but then here's the dairy
farmers here's the people who live in
town and all can walk to the same public
school and parish that then their
representative would be a representative
it would mean something instead of being
this sort of partisan scorekeeping or
something like that they there's no
there's no almost no common interest
between the people at the Bethesda
Country Club and the people in Allegheny
County Maryland and and so that's the
sort of thing so local governance
restoring local governments would be a
big thing but also having representation
be something that means something would
be it would be significant good thank
you questions from the audience
yes in the blue checkered shirt there
sure microphone coming Tim thanks for
coming
you touched really briefly when you're
talking about your anecdote about a
working-class guy in 1955 Pittsburgh
area that his wife could stay home if
she wanted to I think that the shift in
women in the workplace in the past 50
whatever years is certainly a really
interesting economic question sort of
doubling the supply of workers I want to
know you know before we get a chance to
dig into your book is it an interesting
question for you in your wheelhouse of
community oh yeah if it's not feel free
to say no and take another question
absolutely I'm not the person to write a
book about say at home wives I think one
should be written but not by a male
probably but I will say this when you
talk about communities you just you talk
about the moms who would sit on the
front porch and scold you if you were
you know being an idiot and would would
would be the ones to see the kid wipe
out on the bike and take care of them
having a person at home now you could
argue it could be a husband or whatever
a single income family it has so many
advantages for building community and
again just for me that when the what I
did with the tea ball last year in our
parish was started like a cookout so my
wife saying at home was able to get all
the food and she would actually order it
on from the internet but still be able
to be there organize it in the car so
that when I got home from work it was
all there and laid out and I could just
go straight to the field and start
grilling and the people who were there
earlier weren't even say all moms but
moms who had jobs that got off earlier
and were more flexible and here's a
great irony in the elite communities
married women are more likely to have
part-time jobs than in the middle class
in the working class who had full-time
who are more likely to have full-time
jobs so women either staying at home or
working part-time it's sort
au curve the the poorest and the
wealthiest so you want to see one reason
why the elites are doing well more
likely to have women with part-time or
full-time jobs plus of the effects on
wages and that sort of thing and again
as with a lot of the problems I'm
pointing to we're not going to have
legislative stuff here but I would like
to see legislation there was one guy who
wrote on Twitter the other day we had
gotten all the way through without
Twitter Twitter yes an argument for he
was saying there's their arguments for a
daycare subsidy instead of paid leave or
per child subsidy and they arguing for a
daycare subsidy is that will get women
into the workforce better and provide
though the employment for the daycare
people rather than the economically
inefficient thing of women leaving the
workforce to in an unpaid ways to take
care of their kids and public policy
maybe ought to favor paid labor over
unpaid labor so that's a mindset that
exists and probably has guided some of
our policy so I would say at least
abolish that that framework in public
policy yes please hi thank you very much
my question is how do you see the rise
of Technology in social media impacting
all of the different sections of society
we were trying to avoid Twitter yes for
one Twitter allows me to see these
really bad arguments the same person on
Twitter also was arguing that people
should stop cooking for themselves and
should just have Soylent for dinner
that's this is a real thing it's not
just named after that and and otherwise
order out because that's more
economically efficient I think social
media in general to date has been a
negative impact on community cohesion by
just drawing people away from their
physical environment and if you have
kids nephews nieces neighbors and you
end up in an environment what it's like
you don't get to see your uncle that
much and you're just going to be staring
at your phone you
I I think that it's clear the best thing
about social media is using it to
connect people so that they can then get
together physically and this is
something I need to get better at is
making the case as to why being
physically with people and then being
present with them is good because it
seems so obvious to me and so many
people I talk to you but sometimes
people say you have to argue why
physical proximity is better than my
virtual group and it's it's a pretty big
divide I'm sure there are people have
written very good books and essays on
this but now being a mammal for instance
exactly and and that was actually
somebody who was explaining to me it was
about chess I was teaching my kids to
play chess and there's one point where
we were passing an iPad back and forth
to each other is like if you play this
in real chest you'd be sitting across
from your child there's two that blind
were us bonding about having
black-and-white screens on our phone yes
setting our iPhones to be black and
white so they were less addictive so I
do think that technology definitely
changed this way we interact I don't
think it's inevitable that this will be
negative in the long term humans are
very adaptive and while I was arguing
that we don't see clearly always our
need for connection I think we sort of
naturally build structures that connect
us and so it could be twenty years from
now I'll be writing about how all these
technologies of the last ten years have
really connected us in a way that we
were less connected in the past but as
it is now as it's sort of a shock and a
disturbance of the way humans interact I
think it is pushing us towards
atomization yes please in front here in
the checkered dress so we live in
America that about 25% of all the
population is either immigrant or a
first-generation American so for a lot
of those people some of the institutions
that you mentioned like church or
serving the community other than your
own family or especially baseball a kind
of foreign and irrelevant
how do you think some of the solutions
that you mentioned are gonna pan out in
this new America that we have right now
so I I do talk about immigration in a
couple different ways for one actually
Hispanic Catholics are more resilient in
their church-going regardless of their
income white Catholics who if something
happens and they make less money they're
more likely to stop going to church and
white catholics are who are poor or less
likely to among Hispanics of church
attendance is Hispanic Catholics the
church attendance is higher and I
imagine something is true like that for
the evangelical so there are ways in
which the on the but then also the
Muslim Americans and this includes
Muslim immigrant Americans are more
likely to say things like with hard work
you can get ahead in America they're
more likely to say that than the average
American is and one of the stories I
tell in the book is about a guy who he
was Bangladeshi Muslim in Texas working
behind a counter at a 7-eleven and
shortly after 9/11 a guy came in and
shot him and his two colleagues a hate
crime
revenge for September 11 two guys died
the one guy survived and as he recovered
he started researching his victim why
would this guy do this any research
where this working-class white guy lived
in Texas and just was so despairing his
view of this immigrant from Bangladesh
his view of America was community and
people coming together and he had his
his Muslim community and he saw other
you know people either you know really
nice towns around Dallas or Christian
community and then he learned that huge
part of the people around him
native-born white working-class had this
total alienation and so the fact is
immigrants do better in America than
native-born work
glass whites for a lot of people we
stayed away from politics even longer
than we stayed away from Twitter or a
lot of trumps early base that was
evidence of some conspiracy by the
elites against the regular guy oh well
they're just giving gifts to the
immigrants and that's why they're doing
better than us no it's because a lot of
times and often based around religion
the immigrants were immigrant
communities were more likely to just be
tight-knit and so this guy who's is
Bangladeshi immigrants I have the best
of both worlds I have a network of
Muslim Asian immigrant neighbors but
also sort of the opportunity of America
and the pluralism of America work and
reach outside that so uh on the
immigrant question I think that for me I
see it as sort of a beautiful aspect of
the refreshing of the American Dream
that new people are coming in but the
dark side is as Robert Putnam found
diversity and social cohesion don't
often go together and I tell the story
in there of my my next-door neighbor who
his name is mr. Patel and the way I get
to know neighbors you see as I say hey I
got this one neighbor Tony's from
Portugal Tony want to come over for a
beer Tony comes over for beer we chat he
tells me about his job he works up in
the top of those really high cranes
that's awesome we have a good chat he
goes to st. parish I see him almost
every week and we borrow tools from each
other mr. Patel you like to come over
for a drink explains he doesn't drink
alcohol because of his religion he's a
hearty Krishna
mr. Patel would you like to come over
for coffee no coffee mr. Patel they got
herbal tea and he starts explaining to
me why this violates his religion I say
okay I've got Lyme Lucroy
putting your water in a can or a bottle
like that it's destructive of God's
creation and so you know I hope you're
not offended Tim but for religious
purposes I can't come over so finally I
had to say to him and like the most
awkward way you could say mr. Patel the
standard way I get to know a guy is by
consuming a fluid with him which which
fluids do you actually consume and he
said water with some like lemon or lime
in it so I sent Lucy and Charlie off to
the store they get a lemon and a lime we
fill up two pitchers put the lime in one
the lemon and the other cut into pieces
and get to know each other over gallons
of gently Citra fied water and we did it
but it was an immense hurdle because of
we didn't even have a language barrier
he speaks flawless English but we just
had a cultural barrier and communities
that have language barriers are going to
have more obstacles to that so that's my
main concern about immigration is if you
have a language barrier and you have a
cultural barrier it makes it much more
laborious to build the social cohesion
and I think that's always been a problem
in the u.s. and so you sometimes get
people ghettoizing and but then those
can become great sores I mean I know so
many sort of like oh well Hell's Kitchen
and there's all these Irish kids and
it's Jimmy Mack in ER I mean it doesn't
sound that different than our friends
our names yeah yeah good okay I think we
have time for one last question yes
right there in the sports coat there I
thank you for coming out in the lovely
weather so when you're analyzing the
exogenous shocks to something like
Pittsburgh due to globalist competition
how do you account for the difference
between the good and the tragic outcomes
of that like a low-income family that
can now afford more nutritional food
because a big business realizes
economies of scale we Zavvi a kid that
gets hooked on drugs overdoses by his
uncle who is becoming unemployed and
doesn't know what to do is his life how
do you account for that difference yeah
I mean how do you weigh them against one
another ID that I thought about that
some while writing the book and I just I
don't think I could do it I mean I can
say the economy of the u.s. is better
off because of immigration and because
of free trade and I can say there are
places where the costs are immense and
they're not merely economic but they're
literally deaths of despair there Jenner
intergenerational this erosion of human
capital people not getting good
education people not people getting
pregnant out of wedlock having one kid
who then does the same thing you know I
don't know how to weigh them against one
another and a some extent I don't think
I have to because it's not my decision
to whether to make this happen or keep
making this happen
we're not gonna reverse it with the
right tariffs or whatever or the right
subsidies for these factories because if
you did that you'd end up with robot
factories and that sort of thing but I
do think one of the chapters in there
the the subtitle is progress at a price
and this is a big thing a lot of the
work I do in here is trying to reach
across to both right and left at the
same time and to say yes we've had
immense progress since 1950s racial the
fact that women can go to college and
get good education more women are in
grad school now not that I think grad
schools necessarily a great idea but
more women are in grad school than men
sorry dr. Mann and but that the the
progress that again it's not just me
being able to get cheaper shoes for my
kids that just means they might have two
pairs of shoes it's a person who might
not be able to buy shoes that fit their
kids being able to get them that's one
of the great benefits of China trade
right so there are real benefits on both
sides and just that progress has come at
a price since I'm not I don't believe
the central planning will work I don't
know that I have to weigh them against
each other but I do I think it's key to
articulate just as we did with
stay-at-home moms
versus more working mothers this social
change whatever progress it represents
it also has a huge cost and we
not discussing the nature of our society
well if we're not discussing both of
them so sorry that's not a great
satisfying answer but but so many of
these things the problem is people
thinking okay a central plan can come up
with just the right answer but
everything I'm talking about here it's
gonna be a lot more complicated a lot
more organic if it's happening on 20,000
little platoons on on a community level
well Tim I know you when you talked
about alienating or alienation you said
one of the key things is they cannot see
the use of plugging back into community
thank you very much for starting the
vision yeah thanks for coming thank you